[Music]
Godzilla Kong the new Empire is bringing
to us a new breed of Titans that would
be Miles Ahead in strength and Powers
than the ones we have already seen in
previous movies these Titans alongside
Godzilla and Kong will have special
abilities and weapons as well so here in
this video we will showcase these powers
and weapons of the big four that is Kong
Godzilla scaring and shimu so let's get
to it let's start with Godzilla so most
of us know that by now Godzilla will be
seen in two different forms in this
upcoming movie just as he was seen in
three different forms in the series
Monarch the legacy of monsters in gxc
the new Empire Godzilla would display
his older blue irradiated form that he
evolved into during the Monarch series
well chronologically that is and then
later he will emerge from an iy crysters
that he got himself into to and he will
come out in his new evolved form the
Ping Zilla with this new body structure
are certain weaponized parts and these
are what we will discuss right here so
obviously the first one is his ping
Atomic Powers the change in coloration
isn't just for new toy sales not just
it's also due to the fact that Godzilla
will be absorbing a new form of Hollow
Earth Energy the Ping radiation why pink
or magenta you may ask well if you take
a look at any electromagnetic spectrum
or energy Spectrum chart you would see
that pink Violet that color has way more
energy and frequency than the light blue
coloration so what does this imply well
it infers that the strength and
temperature of the atomic breath of
godzill will be at least one magnitude
higher therefore giving him a deadly
attack one which could overpower the
deadly proton scream of mega Godzilla if
given a chance this new Atomic breath
will be powered and stored in the new
pink crystalline dorsal place that he
would de developed in his icy crystals
the ones on his back the second
weaponized spot of Godzilla are the
elbow spikes which are made of the same
crystalline formations as the new dorsal
plates these elbow spikes along with his
longer arms and Slimmer physique with
give the Gman a new form of melee
fighting style he could slash and cut
with those he would also have longer
reach with his arms and then move with
high the enemy Titans to sleep on Buck
style along with these new body
structures he would also have a Aizer at
the end of the tail for those that don't
know Aizer is a spiky ending that quite
a few ancient animals have like the
stegosaurus of the Jurassic era this
tagam Miser would be armed with the same
crystalline spikes and it can be used to
slash to stab and to impale enemy Titans
and given that the tail of Godzilla is
long and muscular The Swinging force it
would create would end in a very high
penetration power for the thiza tips
this would mean sudden death for lesser
Titans and Grievous wounds to the ones
that have armored skin like
shimu now let's go to the next Titan
Kong well in the beginning scenes of the
movie as seen in the trailer he would
still possess the GVK battle axe this is
an ancient relic weapon of the Kongs
that they use in an ancient war against
the Gojira species the blade of this
weapon is made of a sharpened dorsal
plate of a dead Godzilla while its
handle is made out of a mutal thigh bone
this weapon can cut slash and hack other
Titans and was used to a great effect
during the battle against Mecha Godzilla
in GVK its slashing power can be
enhanced by Godzilla's Atomic breath as
was seen when Kong fought Mecha G and it
was able to cut through the robot
Titan's body with relative ease after it
absorbed the energy of the atomic breath
but somewhere along the way in the movie
in this new movie Kong would lose the ax
this is not to say that it'll be
permanent he could regain it in the end
of the film in the final battle so when
K would speculatively lose to a battle
with the scar King in the first half of
the new movie he would lose the battle
axe and then have his arm broken this is
where the Beast glove comes in Beast is
an acronym and the full form is
bioenhanced anatomic seismic Thunder
glove this mechanical Contraption is
going to be a creation of Monarch it
would give Kong the ability to use his
broken arm to the same degree as he did
without the injury theoretically this
Mecha glove would be made out of the
strongest metal alloy known to man an
alloy that can break rock and withstand
heavy pressure and temperature this
metal would be in theory denser and more
durable than the Titan bones and
therefore would give cor a greater
punching power it could also have a
rocket booster on the elbow part on the
end to accelerate the punch to a higher
speed just like how Mecha Godzilla
displayed while fighting Godzilla in GVK
and who knows it might also deliver
electric high voltage shocks to every
punch Kong makes just like Mecha
Godzilla again Mona could adapt the ATT
behind the Mecha G to this glove and
therefore enhance the fighting
capabilities of Kong and also giving him
the electric powers that he had during
the 1962 King Kong versus Godzilla movie
something which the fans have always
demanded now let's go to the enemy
Titans of the movie starting with the
scar King so in the trailer we were
shown slight glimpses of this gigantic
red ape enemy Titan and in those scenes
he was seen to have some sort of a Titan
whip weapon which was caught around his
body it looked like a spinal column of a
dead Titan a serpentine one maybe a
warbat or a dead specimen of a tiamut
this weapon would be super long and
would give the red ape a huge advantage
in range during melee combat it could
also be tipped with the spiky sharp
crystals of the hollow Earth therefore
further enhancing its slicing power and
if used in a proper way it can also be
caught around the neck of Kong or
Godzilla suffocating the Titan
combatants and at the same time the
crystalline SP would dig deep into the
Flesh of these Titans another Attack
Mode would be to whip it so fast in a
straight line that it would be able to
impale an enemy Titan and given that the
scar King is old and highly experienced
this form of attack might be employed
the scaring could also theoretically
have different abilities like new
abilities like mind control or maybe a
mind control weapon that he can use to
control shimu but that is up to the
movie to tell us okay the last Titan
here of of course is the ancient shimu
he has not been shown yet in the trailer
or the posters but the toy leaks and the
clothing logos show this beast in full
and in the toy covers we have his full
miniature appearance along with the
description of his power the frostbite
blast this power is theorized to be
shima's range attack and it is the
complete opposite of the power of
Godzilla which is for all intents and
purposes and extremely hot fire shimo
frostbite on the other hand would be an
extremely cold icy blast that can freeze
Titans in place due to this power and
his Frost abilities shimu is now
speculated to be actually the one that
froze Monster Zero gidora in place in
Antarctica given that Godzilla couldn't
have done it since his powers are hot
not cold so in this new movie we will no
doubt get another Dragon Ball Z duel
with Godzilla breathing his pink flame
against shimu with his icy bluish white
frostbite blast and lastly shimu isn't
just a Titan that would Breathe In icy
power and run away he or it is said to
be the most powerful Titan and this one
is armed with massive claws a robust
body spiky crystalline dorsal plates and
also Aizer just like that of evolved
Godzilla and while Godzilla would have
this as a new weapon something which he
has to learn how to use shimu the
ancient one would have had thousands of
years of practice and experience and
therefore would use it on Instinct
rather than conscious thought so that's
all the new powers and weapons that the
titans of Godzilla Kong the new Empire
would possess and use in the upcoming
flake now if you like this video then
check this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other most
diverse content we might just have
things that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care
fam